hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in round
4 of the 2015 norway chess tournament we
have a cool match today two of the top
four players in the world rematch of the
2014 World Chess Championships why it's
gonna be played by none other than Vichy
and non-blacks going to be played by
Magnus Cross in manga Carlsen having a
rough go in his home country he started
out with two losses first round lost
because of time when he had a winning
position next round did not play very
well made a mistake and it cost him and
then the last round had a tie so he
needs to really get back on his horse
and start getting some wins even drawls
are going to be tough with such a strong
feel here so we'll go ahead and get into
it Vichy non starts with Pawnee for
Pawnee 5 9 f 396 and then Bishop you to
b5 Magnus Carlsen running into the right
Lopes quite often and it's been kind of
customary for him to play the Berlin
defense Knight to f6 decides to start
with something a little bit different so
excited for something new always fun to
see that so pawn to a6 we see Bishop
back here to a4 sex some of the more
common don't see the exchange variation
as much Bishop taking here on c6 let me
see Knight to f6 and then castle on the
King side Bishop here to e7 bish 57
maybe not the most common play that
you'll see you may see Bishop to c5
that's an option you could see pawn here
to d6 right away you could even see
Knight to e4 besides to go for Bishop to
e7 getting ready for a quick castle on
the kingside pawn to d3 pawn to d6 and
then pawn to c3 so a little interesting
a white did have the option of first
bringing his knight here to c3 all of
these are fine they're all kind of
created equal in some respect it's all
about the preparation that these players
have so they've probably studied many
many many hours with other teammates
some of their training partners to go
over some of these specific lines so
pawn to c3 this is going to kind of
block off this knight but looking to
bring the knight here to d2 and then get
it involved somewhere
else on the board can always come to see
for if it needs to can always come over
here to f1 it's a common thing we'll see
after the rook over here to e1 and then
try to count to start an attack on the
king side so casts on the Kings side for
Magnus Carlsen and then Knight to d2 as
we talked about rook over here to e8 so
no pieces coming off the board no no
pawn exchanges or anything so both sides
playing somewhat you know non aggressive
not really trying to do anything too
crazy yet we now see rook over here to
e1 upon to b5 forcing the bishop that
back the bishop can come to be 3 or C 2
both are going to be fine machine on
decides to go ahead and come back here
with bishop here to see - bishop back
here to f8 so both sides you know stay
in kind of back there they're not being
too aggressive on both fronts Knight
here to f1 as we talked about one of the
options just kind of maneuvering all of
the pieces over to the King side upon to
g6 maneuvering the bishop a little round
so the bishop will eventually come here
to g7 being Fink head out here on the g7
square instead of this e 7 which early
on it doesn't make too much of a
difference it's kind of a log jam here
in the middle so it doesn't matter that
moving some of these minor pieces twice
your opponent doesn't have a ton of room
to kind of move and take advantage of
that so it's completely fine to kind of
maneuver this bishop back here to f8
where it was and then come to g7 now we
see pawn to h3 Bishop here to b7 Knight
to g3 so white looking to eventually
attack on the King side has both of the
Knights here if ever wants to kind of
jump in maybe the Knight to g5 could
always come 9 2 h 2 the Knight to g4
nice little outpost attacking this
Knight if you had a bishop here on g5
have a you know pin down piece to the
Queen so the Queen might want to move
some of the options that machine on has
later in the game night to b8 is a
pretty interesting move this is the
Brier variation it became kind of famous
in the 1960s when Spassky played it
played it very very well
why
always had a tough time really knowing
what to do it kind of looks weird you
bring your knight here to c6 and then a
little bit later on you bring it back
here to b8 but this actually does a lot
for black it allows them to open up the
board for the LightSquared bishop to
kind of control this long diagonal it
also opens up for this C pawn to
actually start pushing forward usually
in the rye Lopez defense specifically
this pawn here on c7 doesn't move much
so now that we've castled on the King
side for black this pawn can push
forward put a lot pressure on the Queen
side the knight can always come over
here to d7 protect this pawn here on e5
so going to be completely fine for black
as Magnus Carlsen is trying to find some
weird variation that he can kind of
break through and hopefully get a win
against Vichy and on pawn to d4 looking
to potentially break up the center of
the board we still have no pieces come
off the board at all no pawns going
anywhere
Knight to d7 we did talk about this move
probably gonna happen
pawn over here to a4 kind of looking to
attack on the Queen side this pawn here
on b5 is somewhat threatening for blacks
it just kind of counter attacking here
with a four it's interesting because at
any time white could just kind of blow
things up could play pawn taking here on
d5 after the exchange we could see some
pieces come off the board we could see
whitey can take here on d8 and all of a
sudden almost all the big pieces in the
center of the board are gone we have
some opening here both sides trying to
jockey to gain control of the D file
both sides still have bishop pears so
that you may try to open up the board a
little bit more but more than likely
it's it's probably to go down to a draw
in game but the sides instead of that to
play pawn here to 1/4 and then pawn here
to c5 - crossing counter attacking on
the Queen side as well pawn here to d5
kind of locking this LightSquared Bishop
up which i think is great plan anytime
you can limit the squares your
opponent's can move that's always going
to be good things so this gained some
space for Vichy and on this lechera
Bishop this dark square Bishop is not
going anywhere so it's you know it could
eventually come here to g7 but even
that's not doing
too much it's kind of blocked by both
this night and this pond so vision on is
going to be able to have a much more
active game with his bishops the
LightSquared Bishop may not be as active
as the dark-squared bishop but all in
all the chignon probably has a slightly
better position in this board state than
Magnus Carlsen now we see pawn to c4
Bishop here to g5 vision on getting his
pieces more involved into the action he
has the most aggressive bishop in the
game so decides to go ahead and get that
out here pin down this Knight to the
queen very important the Queen can
always come to c7 I really like this
move just don't even have to worry about
it you do have the night here on d7
which isn't going really anywhere else
right now potentially if he wanted to
use this outpost on c5 he definitely
could but right now it's doing fine just
holding down the fort to this night here
on f6 so it could always play the Queen
here to c7 if you wanted to decide to
the first play bishop here to g7 this
way even if he plays Queen to c7 he can
still bring his knight to c5 great
outpost move attacking this pawn central
square that White's going to have to
deal with as far as protecting that so
that's going to be something Magnus
Carlsen is going to be looking at Queen
here to d2 rook over here to b8 and then
Knight to h2 if we kind of look at
White's board state as far as the
options he has so far neither side has
really blinked first we don't have any
material off the board
it's very clogged up right now if we
look at White's options he can always
retreat his Bishop back Bishop here to
e3 is completely fine both sides have
been moving their pieces back and
forward just small improvements waiting
to see what their opponents does doesn't
necessarily want to blow up maybe the
Queen side right now the rook has come
over here recognizing that hey something
may happen on this B file that's going
to be fine the rook could always come
here to let's say a three you know maybe
he wants to kind of double barrel bring
his other rook over here's a one that's
completely fine break open this Queen
file over here on the a rank and then
you know start to push forward that's
good we could also see the Queen come to
e3 another option right here none of
these are really putting too much
pressure on black
doesn't really tell magnus carlsen that
busy wants to do anything crazy but
night 2h2 basically says it's go time
because there's no reason to do night
2h2 unless you are looking to play
Knight to g4 and g4 signifies hey we're
getting ready to rumble on the kingside
I'm going for an attack so magnus
carlsen has to look at this and say okay
this nights going to come here to g4
then you're going to be putting a lot of
pressure on my own knight on f6 and it's
being pinned down to the Queen on d8 and
that is very problematic to deal with me
personally I would just take this
opportunity and just play my Queen to c7
keep it safe Magnus Carlsen decides to
go for a little different option plays
Bishop here to c8 then we see Knight to
g4 s we talked about vision on deciding
to start to attack on the Kings side now
Knight to c5 we do see the outpost from
Magnus Carlsen and then Knight up here
to h6 now this is check and so black has
to deal with that but if we come back
and look okay so let's say instead of
the bishop to b7 or to C 8 we see Queen
to c7 now if the knight were to come up
here we could see an exchange off the
board after the pawn takes then all of a
sudden Knight comes down here to c5
White has double pawns on the G file
all of a sudden black has a nice little
outpost here there's no huge threat this
Knight can't come here to f5 can't come
here to h5 because of this pawn right
here the black king is completely
protected and it's very easy now for
Magnus Carlsen to get his up Bishop
involved Bishop here to c8 can now
attack this pawn here it's somewhat
awkward for Vichy and on to try to hold
on to that less he wants to open up the
dark squares along this diagonal right
here so I like this position better
manage Carlsen decided to go for another
option so the bishop here to c8 is the
line they take but I always like to go
over some additional lines that you may
not see in the game that some of the
commentators that were going over the
game and myself as I was kind of
watching it were thinking about as well
so
Knight to c5 now Knight up to h6 check
we do see in exchange off the board and
then the pawns taking here on a for now
black is up material right now and white
could decide to go ahead and take the
material back decides to go in first
play rook here to a2 knowing that this
pawn could be captured
if white wants to he does have both his
rook and his bishop both on yet but
asides first to play a rook here to a to
a now pawn to a3 saying okay I know I'm
going to lose this material but that's
going to be completely okay
if we come back I think white even had
another option he could have played
bishop here to e3 knowing that this rook
could take but if the rook takes here on
b2 he does have some options the bishop
could take here on c5 if we do see an
exchange on board now the Queen comes
back here to a c1 the works going to
have to move now the bishop can take
black has a horrible pawn structural
double pawns on the C file without
anything on the B or D file that's not
going to be good white has a very active
position so I see that there was a
threat here on b2 but I think it'd be
completely okay to just bring the bishop
back here to e3 and even if the the
Queen were to come let's take Queen to
c7 trying to hold down the fort with the
night here on c5 we could still see the
bishop take and then the Queen take and
now the bishop takes here on a 4 and the
rook can't really come down here to be
to it's protected by the Queen but even
more than that the bishop is attacking
this rook here on e8 so some of the
other options that vision on had decided
to play it a little closer to the vest
and just play the rook here to a2 and
then Magnus Carlsen giving that material
back pawn here to a3 and then we just
see the pawn take here on a3 Magna
Springs is Knight back here to d7 and
then pawn to f4 pretty aggressive move
from Vichy Nani had some other options
as far as pulling a little bit maybe
more passive but decides to just go for
the jugular pawn here to f4 trying to
blow stuff up he kind of has his
opponent on the rope right here
and so decides to just continue to
attack upon here to a5 Brooke over here
to f1 since you're going to be pushing
pawns your rooks always belong your
pawns as you're pushing them semi open
files open files or just important files
and this F file all of a sudden it
became pretty important so he brings his
rook over here now we're going to see
pawn here to f6 pawn here to f5 so Vichy
and ons pushing forward
Knight to d2 or d3 definitely a nice
outpost but vision on he doesn't really
care too much about his lights for a
bishop it has not been doing anything
all game long it's been kind of just
sitting there so decides hey here's a
great opportunity to go ahead and
exchange off the board right now comes
back here to Queen to d1 doesn't have to
worry right now about this pawn it's not
using a it doesn't have a huge threat
right now there's no way for black to
really push forward and so decides to
just hey let's improve the position I
have a strong attack going over here on
the King side so let's focus on that
rook here to e7 Manglish cousin
recognize that hey I got to start to
build up a defense because V she's
coming for me rook over here to F to
rook here to f7 and now the Queen
decides to go ahead and take Knight here
to c5 the outpost that he had Knight on
before Queen over here to f3 so all of
the material kind of lined up to start
to attack Magnus Carlsen on the kingside
Magnus though if we look at it he still
doesn't have a active light to her
vision is that lights where bishop
hasn't done much all game long it's kind
of bounced back between b7 and c8 but
hasn't really had a lot of room to move
this night here on c5 has a nice outpost
on the completely opposite side of the
board the work here on b8 is controlling
the only open file on the board
completely away from the action so you
may have heard this in some of my other
videos if you've kind of been watching
for a while it's not about the material
you have it's about the material you
have in the fight ambition on it just by
looking at this board state we can tell
he has a lot of material in the fight
Magnus Carlsen is going to have to find
a creative way to get out of this
because he's going to have a lot of
material flying out his King
very very soon Magnus now plays his
Bishop to a6 attacking this rook here on
f1 vision on could care less because he
has way too many pieces attacking he's
just going to let this go if Magnus
Carlsen wants to take it pawn to g5 and
then punt up here to h4 kind of breaking
this open I'm not even sure if Magnus
Carlsen realized hey pawns h4 just kind
of blows all this up pawn can't take so
decides to go ahead and take this rook
here on f1 again vision on does not care
too much but he decides to go ahead and
take it with his rook now we see the
Queen to d7 we see the pawn take here on
g5 would you see an exchange right here
Queen up here to h5 just improving the
position and then pawn to f6 now I
really thought vision I was just going
to take with this Queen right here and
then you could see the route come over
here to g8 and then Queen back here to
h4 I think this is completely fine but
the more I've looked at it I really like
vision odds play pawn here to f6 now
after rook here to g8 Bishop here to g7
is a great outpost move it essentially
forces black to make an exchange right
here and now have this open file for
this rook here to control and white
really still has this very aggressive
Queen right here on h5 much better than
it was in the previous example that I
just showed so this is very good Magnus
Carlsen as we can tell has to take this
because his King can't move anywhere so
after the take right here we now see
Knight coming up here to a5 outpost
attacking the Queen the Queen is forced
to move and then after the exchange
right here we see the knight come up
here to e7 Kings going to move and then
taking the rook here on g6 and then the
risk is going to become very very potent
getting behind the enemy lines and he
can just pretty much gobble up all of
this material a rook is always going to
dominate a knight in the in game so even
though both sides have equal material as
far as pawns the rook is just so far
better than the
when it's night it's just not even funny
so upon ea4 Knight to c4 and then after
just a few more moves not here to f2 and
magnus carlsen is forced to resign so
congratulations to Vichy and on I'm not
sure if he just uh you know smelt water
in the blood in the water because Magnus
Carlsen has just been getting pounded
this entire tournament or if you just
decided hey I'm tired of playing pass up
against Magnus Carlsen he's beat me in
the last two World Championships I'm
just going to come out play my game be
super aggressive which he's typically
not against Magnus Carlsen and then just
see what happens but that's what he did
he was super aggressive it paid off
Magnus Carlsen was pretty much playing
defense the entire time couldn't really
get his pieces activated they were just
back here kind of dancing around never
had an opportunity to have any sort of
counter play on any of the board fishing
on too much pressure so Magnus Carlsen
is gonna have to find some miracle if he
wants to come back and even place
decently in this tournament fishy and on
now puts himself in contention to win
this thing definitely in the medal stand
for sure so fantastic match just in
round four we've seen some fantastic
play usually going to happen when you
have the best players in the world in
one tournament so hopefully you guys
enjoyed I will see you guys in round 5
thanks for watching